all right so for full disclosure this is
a sponsored video by more fun Studios
but one I think you'll find surprisingly
interesting several years ago this
spectacular parkour sequence went viral
across the internet and I remember being
so completely blown away by it at the
time it's hard enough animating one
person so well but to do so with
multiple people and integrated
seamlessly with 3D backgrounds that's
the kind of stuff that made me fall in
love with Attack on Titan first day this
is hitor noita the outcast and turns out
it's not a parkour Ane at all this is a
Balls to the- Wall mystical martial arts
story with some of the sickest action
I've yet seen remember when boro's 65th
episode exploded onto the internet and
just blew people's minds well that very
same team appeared on this anime and
melted my brain with the most stunning
hand toand choreograph fight scenes and
man when the elemental blast started
flying I knew I was in for a real tree
this is the type of content I love and
interestingly this is a Chinese Japanese
collaboration it's a real stunner but
when a video game adaptation was
announced my first thought was can a
game even begin to capture the nuances
of this action well I'm Mark Fitzpatrick
and today I want to answer that burning
question this is Project the
outcast from that intro alone it's hard
to not feel exceptionally optimistic
about that question but before diving
into the action itself I want to rewind
a bit to the parts of this game that
aren't action heavy while the Outcast
absolutely Soares with its martial arts
sequencing it's the atmosphere of its
downtime the moments of horror that ooze
with atmosphere that I think make it a
compelling series and from looking at
the first reveal trailer it doesn't seem
to be lacking in that regard the
lighting in this horror sequence is
stunning I was 100% convinced that this
was pre-rendered Gameplay at first given
that this is releasing on mobile first
and foremost before it's transitioning
to Mainline platforms later on down the
line the way the colored lights bounce
off of the environment looks insane and
the Deep Shadows whether it be the
ambient occlusions of objects against
the walls or the dynamic Shadows Through
the Windows as a creepy figure crawls
past it's all seriously impressive the
mobile space has definitely seen
gigantic leaps in visuals over the years
I mean anyone with a Nintendo switch or
steam deck can attest to that but the
actual core mobile phone space has only
been improving year on year for my money
this type of 2D anime visual style has
effectively being solved in the mobile
space it looks fantastic and it'll be
very interesting to see how this all
shapes up for the full release of course
it is the action that I'm here for first
and foremost and man it does not
disappoint the speed and fluidity of the
combat is 100% there but it's actually
the smaller details that I think make
this so impressive when you look at some
of the best anime action the animation
techniques used feature several Staples
that add real oomph to the impacts you
have things like smears where the limbs
momentarily lose form to convey extra
speed motion you have impact effects
those sort of smokey wind flourishes you
often see and of course you can't forget
the actual pivotal gestures of the
characters to sell the movement it's
awesome to go frame by frame through
this trailer and actually see all of
these techniques put into practice
dynamically smearing a 3D model is
certainly not the easiest thing in the
world but I really like the way they're
achieving it here alongside the per
object motion blur the little camera
shakes with each impact doing a great
job of tricking your brain about the
insanity of these blows but well I don't
think I can emphasize enough just how
impressive this actual animation work is
underneath all that it turns out the
team at Mor fun Studios fully motion
captured huge chunks of the gameplay
with legitimate martial artists which
they then took and sped up refined and
baked into the results you can now see
on screen it's a really interesting
approach for a stylized anime game
especially in an era where trying to
emulate the modulated frame rate of
traditional 2D anime has become a new
trend it's very much an intentional
decision though and what I think is
essential given the series's huge
emphasis on fluidity so much so in fact
that the team have created a
collaboration that honors Bruce Lee in
particular his b water philosophy which
technically he took from Buddhist
philosophy but we're going to forget
about that empty your
mind be formless shapeless like water
though you put water into a cup it
becomes the cup you put water into a
bottle it becomes the bottle you put it
in a teapot it becomes the teapot I love
Bruce Lee like so many I grew up
watching his movie and have always been
fascinated by his martial arts jet kundo
which he himself devised With It
featuring a lot of that philosophical
messaging of be like water at its core
it's an analogy that applies to all
aspects of life to be like water is to
be adaptable it's to look at your
surroundings analyze your situation and
mold to it like water poured into a cup
of course that's a bit of a narrow
surface level reading but it's an
impactful one and one that ultimately
defined his martial arts he didn't want
his students to learn pre re arrang
patterns of a specific martial arts type
over and over he wanted them to have a
vast knowledge and to be adaptable to be
fluid and everchanging and you can
really feel the Creator's love and
respect for this pouring out onto this
trailer and even when it kicks back into
gameplay with its larger than live Chi
blasts the key philosophies can still be
found underneath take this moment for
example the player character here
attends to block and counter but the
opponent uses a throw to break his guard
and counter in one smooth motion it
feels like it kind of embodies Lee's
notion of the economy of motion and
while it's not quite a simultaneous
Paran punch for what I imagine our
balance reasons it has the same kind of
feel to it but even moving away from
that the core mechanics seem genuinely
interesting and what you'd expect from a
competent Fighter the blue flare that
appears on an opponent indicates a skill
is about to be used so it's nice to see
clear telegraphs in action in a way
that's both stylish and unobtrusive the
actual speed of them seems to vary from
move to move I think like the one at the
start of this trailer is kind of slow
but some of the others are clearly going
to require some insane reaction time if
you're going to have any chance of
evading or countering one thing I was
initially concerned about was whether a
more grounded fighter like this could
feel slow if an opponent keeps trying to
maintain distance in a larger Arena so
it's nice to also see flashy Gap closers
included especially with them flowing
smoothly into grabs and Combos and of
course like any good fighter if you've
got a special meter building that move
better be godamn cool and boy does it
deliver
I asked a specific question at the four
of this video can a game even begin to
capture the nuances of this anime's
action and from what I've seen so far it
sure seems like a resounding yes but let
me know what you thought for me this
seems like a game with a lot of
potential if this is a truly accurate
slice of wats to come anim made tie-in
games so often feel dated and unrefined
so it's refreshing to see something that
so clearly has a lot of modern
sensibilities about it the visual design
the Moa action there's a premium feel to
it that I hope it lives up to upon
release from looking at the UI it's
interesting to see a radial menu pop up
for the skills so I'll be curious to see
how much variety there is from character
to character upon release there's a good
chunk of different action styles to pull
from based on the characters in the show
so my hope is that they feel distinct
both mechanically and Visually given PVP
is a pretty major component of the
game's design I'll be very interested to
see
what the player base comes up with upon
launch I know any Dev can tell you that
they can never account for the insanity
players are capable of coming up with so
fingers crossed morphun Studios can stay
on top of things and keep the game well
balanced as they release more and more
fun updates I mentioned it earlier but I
think it Bears repeating it really is
just mind-blowing how far the mobile
space has come over the past few years
to see content like this and understand
that it's evolves the point that it can
be released on both Mainline consoles
and mobile without issue is kind of nuts
for someone like me who's used to
playing I don't know snake on a mobile
phone if you're curious to check these
trailers out without me yapping over
them I'll leave the links to them in the
description gaming is not really
something I've typically delved into
much on this channel but it's a medium
I'm excited about and maybe something
you can look forward to in the future
but for now I want to say thanks once
again to more fun Studios for sponsoring
the coverage of this game and thank you
so much for
watching